dernier coup de coeur dernier coup de
coeur ou coups de corse et c'est chez
moi maman retour et ce que j'ai fait
c'est vraiment ça
ah ouais ingéré m'a aidé beaucoup et
vous voilà dans les coups de poing dans
les coups de poing là je pense je ne
peux pas dire coup de poing qui glisse
ben c'était une luge en plus parce que
je suis assez près alors c'est vraiment
accidentel faisait pas bien avec
quelqu'un qui vérifiait sont pas là les
coups de foudre d'aller coup de foudre
dans les coups de foudre ces tensions à
ce que vous dites ou ne vous inquiétez
pas dans les coups de foudre belle
écoute j'ai cessé mes filles quoi il
faut je suis ici ma fille qui a 4 ans
dès fois me fais moi rhône est grave
kwame brown et moi y la maman collin de
là et là on a un coup de foudre non du
j'ai envie de des fois quand on embarque
à l'école j'ai envie que cette heure
bien si leur vie en quatre heures hier
pour vraiment l'année va chercher la
bouffe est quoi un dernier coup de rouge
d'en découdre où ça fait trois ans que
ça vous devez arrêter de boire
oui mais voilà les blogs n'ont pas de
boulot même pas où pouvaient plus que je
suis dit je pense que je suis devenu un
petit peu méchante reine
parce que quand on voit beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup au mollet n'a le droit
de faire vous l'avez déjà une fois les
revoir il faudra voir vous l'avez dire
avec dernier coup de bluff là maintenant
là maintenant je suis bluffé la dernier
coup de blues d'un et tristesse dans les
coups de blues dans les coups de blues
passé récent vous avez un mauvais un
coup de blues d'un coup de blues
quand on tape à la porte avions ici pour
les impôts là vous donner un conseil à
tous les jeunes chanteurs vous dit de
payer vos impôts un non mais c'est vrai
mais quand on trouve que les impôts leur
donne des chèques et qui qui reviennent
et après c'est injuste des majeures à
s'adresser au président qu'on va lui
c'est ça c'est vous dernière question
dernier coup de rein lui sied
là